Kanye West was interviewed by Tucker
Carlson yesterday it was a wide-ranging
uh interesting interview worth watching
the whole thing if you haven't seen at
one point he addresses the controversy
over his white lives matter shirt that
he wore with Candace Owens a few days
ago and let's watch that
so you said
um that your father said when he saw the
shirt white lives matter it's great to
see a black man stating the obvious so
by which I think you meant that's
obviously true yeah that my favorite
response because I kept on thinking like
you know people they're looking for an
explanation and people say well as an
artist
you don't have to give an explanation
but as a leader you do yes I think
that's right
so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
it's the obvious thing
seems like a simple enough answer I mean
I don't know
um and and one it's not only simple but
it's a it's one that no critic has ever
been able to respond to
so we know there are a lot of criticisms
of saying White lives matter certainly
wearing it on a t-shirt
but they've never been been able to
actually explain the criticism or what
their problem is with it
um if White lives matter why can't we
say so why shouldn't we say so
how could it ever ever under any
circumstance be a bad idea to affirm the
value and dignity
of human life of any human life
and you can't claim see the critics they
can't claim that uh saying White lives
matter means that black lives don't
matter they can't claim that because
they're the ones who've claimed before
that saying black lives matter doesn't
mean that white lives don't matter
I mean that's that's one of their
criticisms of White lives matter is that
it's not necessary to say because when
someone says black lives matter they're
not they're not trying to say that white
lives don't
well if that's the case then there's no
reason not to say White lives matter
because the same's in the reverse
because you're saying White lives matter
doesn't mean black lives don't
I mean we can we can probably assume
that Candace Owens and Kanye West don't
believe that black lives matter that
black lives don't matter given that
they're both black and I would think
that they probably find that their own
lives are valuable
so the only way to understand the
criticism
is that the critics apparently think
that that any time you're affirming the
value of life
of lives it should be black lives so
what they're saying is you know why are
you saying White lives matter when you
could be saying black lives matter
so if you're going to be if you're gonna
go out there declaring that lives matter
then uh if you're doing that then then
it's you're wasting time by saying White
lives you should be saying black lives
matter instead
which which doesn't make any sense
especially when
um there's there's no shortage of people
who are out declaring that black lives
matter so you think it'd be okay every
once in a while for someone to say hey
you know what by the way a white lives
matter too
now what's really underneath all this as
we talked about a few days ago I mean
the the reality is the only reason to
oppose someone even saying that is if
you disagree with it
but the critics aren't going to say that
they're not quite at the point
now you can get away with you can get
away with a lot of anti-white racism in
our culture get away get away with quite
a lot of it
but
we're probably not yet at the point
where it'll be socially acceptable to
just go out and directly say White lives
don't matter at all they're all a bunch
of scumbags and should die you can get
pretty close to that
but the critic but the people who feel
that way certainly certainly seem to
think that they can't go all the way and
actually declare that and so you know
they won't say they'll they'll uh come
up with reasons why you shouldn't say
White lives matter but uh we all know
that the real reason the real reason
they feel that is it is that to them
it's just not true
well if you like me are insecure and
desperate and need more approval and
more respect then uh that's why you need
established titles established titles is
your opportunity to earn the title of
Lord or lady and gain the respect that
you so richly deserve or think you do
anyway all you need is a one square foot
plot of land in Scotland in your title
pack you'll be bestowed with at least
one square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland plus
an official certificate which is what
I'm holding with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion and there are even
couple packs that come with an adjoining
plot of land for the special someone in
your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of Lord
or lady to your credit card plane ticket
and even your dating profiles my wife
has been begging me to take her on a
trip to Europe and so maybe I do this
instead I say we're not going to go but
I got you a square foot plot of land in
Scotland you'll never see it but it's
there and get this established titles
told me that the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my
exclusive link will receive a plot
within a few walking minutes of mine
that's exciting so depending on how many
of you want to become a lawyer lady we
can build our own kingdom established
titles is actually running a massive
sale right now plus if you use code
Walsh you get an additional 10 off so go
to establish titles.com Walsh to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel speaking of lives mattering
Kanye also explained his pro-life stance
which I thought was interesting here's
that
you just landed in the lanyard's still
on from it and there's a photograph on
it what is that it's a photograph of a
baby's ultrasound
why is that and that you designed that
yes why what does that mean well it just
represents life and pro-life
well so you wear it on a badge what kind
of response do you get and good amen I
agree I don't care about people's
responses I care about the fact that
there's more
black babies being aborted than born in
New York City at this point that 50 of
Black Death
in America is abortion so I really don't
care about people's responses I perform
for audience of one and that's God
amen as Doug Carlson said and uh that's
another point that is really impossible
for the left to respond to so they just
they just sort of ignore it
and um
and they they get around it by as they
often do by just
declaring the opposite so they they take
the the opposite position entirely
um even though it doesn't make any sense
and um instead they'll say that no
actually it's uh it's racist it's
anti-black to be pro-life
you know pro-life people are actually
racist
along with being anti-woman and all the
rest of it that well let's throw it all
in and somehow it's homophobic too and
everything to be to be pro-life but it's
also anti-black
just like they can't explain their
criticism of the White lives matter
t-shirt they also can't explain that
especially when this Kanye West points
out
you know if the pro-lifers have their
way
if we have our way
if we really had our way and there was
no more abortion across the entire
country at all it all went away and uh
Planned Parenthood was was thrown on the
historical ass sheep and that was it
that would mean that a lot that many
more black children would be born
and that the black population in America
would increase substantially not just in
numbers now all populations would
increase in numbers white black all
populations if you get rid of abortion
because all races are having abortions
but more than that
black population would increase
substantially in numbers but also in as
a matter of percentage
because right now
um
you know the the black community
accounts for a vastly disproportionate
number of abortions
and so the gains percentage-wise would
be would be disproportionate as well
so that's what you're pro-life that's
part of what you're fighting for
meanwhile on the left they are fighting
to kill more black people and to keep
them you know to keep their sort of
percentages lower that's what that's
what they're doing
but that is the pro-black anti-racist
position they say
in this upside down world of ours since
we're on the subject of black lives
matter now is a good time by the way to
tell you about the premiere of the new
Candace Owens documentary the greatest
lie ever sold which premieres uh finally
on October 12th
and this was going to come out way back
in May you may remember but Candace
decided she wanted to do even more with
it even an even deeper dive and that's
what they've been doing over the past
several months and it was worth the wait
I can tell you Candace is going to
expose the Sham BLM organization and all
the false narratives it has driven and
that it has thrived on
but you can't watch it unless you are a
daily wire plus member uh it look it's
it's just true it's it's a true
statement
that and yes I am biased but it's also
true that nobody is making content like
this
nobody else is
I would I would challenge you to come up
with another company someone else
someone out somewhere else in the
conservative world that's making content
like this this documentary could not
exist on any other platform
it's like what is a woman it's something
that needs to exist uh content that
needs to be made but nobody's making it
but us
and that's why we need you on board as a
subscriber helping us in in the fight
there's a reason why when the left is
you know really going hard at a
conservative media figure trying to take
them down it's almost always you notice
someone here at the daily wire Candace
Ben me I mean there's always like some
conservative trending every week
some conservative in media is like a
main character on Twitter every week but
but never for a good reasons because
they're trying to take us out and it's
almost always someone here at the daily
wire
um or you know there are a few outside
like Tucker Carlson's another one
obviously
but they're very worried about us and
about what we're doing
because we're in this fight we're
fighting to win we are serious about it
this is not just publicity this is not
just content marketing for us
we're putting it on the line and uh we
can
we can do that only because we have the
support of our subscribers we couldn't
do it without you
with you we can and we can win the fight
together
so this is a great time to become a
member of the daily wire if you haven't
you can you can do that now before
October 12th which is the big Premiere
event and
um there's about to be another daily
wire documentary that catches the World
by by storm and you'll see it for
yourself if you become a member so I
would urge you to do that and that'll do
it for us today as we move over to the
members blog hope to see you there if
not talk to you on Monday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]